many of us are listening to those
doctors warnings triple a predicts a 10
decline in thanksgiving travel the
largest one-year drop
since the 2008 recession but that still
means a lot of people are on the move in
spite of the risks
chris van cleave is in washington chris
what can you tell us about what
travelers can expect today
well good morning and happy thanksgiving
typically today is one of the lighter
days for travel driving primarily you
can see not a ton of people
up and on the roads this early but what
we do expect
is that people will be more likely to
drive this year they're
likely to go less far and stay fewer
days now
analysts expect around 48 million people
give or take are expected to be on the
roads this weekend that's a decline from
the nearly 50 million in 2019
with the last push of pre-thanksgiving
travel wrapping up by around noon today
while travel across the country is
expected to be lighter than past years
you may find particularly in major
cities actual
traffic on the way home this weekend
congestion may be
way above normal pandemic levels with
delays of an hour or more expected in
los angeles and san francisco
around 40 minutes in atlanta chicago and
new york now due to the pandemic
aaa expects americans will be monitoring
the public health situation looking at
local quarantine guidelines
before making their plans many at the
last minute which means
these travel forecast numbers could be
considerably lower but typically
sunday is the busiest day both on the
roads
and at the airports last year the tsa
set an all-time
record at their checkpoints for the
number of people that won't happen this
year but it's certainly a day we're
watching
very closely happy thanksgiving vlad
happy thanksgiving to you my friend
chris van cleef thank you so much